اذن نذكر بما تابعناه قبل قليل من اخبار
عاجله نقلا عن وزير الخارجيه الايراني اذ
يقول توصلنا الى اتفاق في مساله تبادل
السجناء مع واشنطن خلال الايام الماضيه
وزير الخارجيه الايراني ايضا قال في حال
تنفيذ الاتفاق مع واشنطن سنشهد تبادل
السجناء خلال فتره قصيره عن تصريحات لوزير
الخارجيه الايرانيه معنا من طهران مراسل
الجزيره نور الدين الدغير نور الدين ماذا
عن هذه
التصريحات وتصب في اي منحى
نعم عبد القادر بكل تاكيد كلام وزير
الخارجيه هنا يتحدث عن صفقه تبادل السجناء
بين ايران والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
اذا ما حاول ان نتحدث عن هذه الصفقه فقط
كان يعمل عليها منذ سنوات لكن الجديد
والذي صاحب تصريح وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه
والحديث على انه تم صك اتفاق في الايام
الاخيره ما بين ايران والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه من اجل اتمام هذه الصفقه يبدو
ان هذه الصفقه تشرف عليها وزاره الخارجيه
الايرانيه ويمكن القول انها ضمن
الاتفاقيات الصغرى التي تجريها ايران مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في ظل تعطل
تنفيذ الاتفاق انه والاشكالات الحاصله في
تنفيذ الاتفاق النووي فالان الانصباب
الاهتمام منصب على مساله تبادل السجناء
هنا لابد من الاشاره عبد القادر على ان
اليوم تم الاعلان من قبل الخارجيه
الايرانيه ومن السفاره الايرانيه في سلطنه
عمان عن وجود السياسي لوزير الخارجيه
الايرانيه علي باقر وهو كبير المفوضين
الايرانيين في سلطنه عمان وكما نعلم على
ان هناك دولتان اساسيتان تعملان الان ضمن
هذا السياق ضمن السياق تبادل السجناء هناك
سلطنه عمان وهناك دوله قطر ووجود نائب
وزير الخارجيه بسلطنه عمان يوشي بان شيئا
ما كانت لدينا بعض المعلومات الصحيحه حول
هذا الموضوع على انه يمكن ان يكون هناك
تبادل للسجناء خلال الايام القليله
المقبله الان وزير الخارجيه يتحدث عن
امكانيه ذلك على امكانيه تبادل السجناء ما
بين ايران والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لكن يقول بان هناك اجراءات تقنيه لابد على
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه من اتخاذها
والان الامر عند الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لاتخاذ هذه الاجراءات اذا ما
اردنا ان نتحدث عن تفاصيل هذه الصفقه في
تبادل السجناء هناك شق اساسي ومهم تركز
عليه ايران وهو الشق المالي والاموال خاصه
اموال الايرانيه المجمده في كوريا
الجنوبيه والمقدر ب 7 مليارات دولار يبدو
ان هذا احدى المحاور المهمه التي كانت في
الوقت السابق في الفترات الماضيه تعرقل
تنفيذ هذا الاتفاق الان حينما يتم الحديث
عن تنفيذ يبدو انه نوع ما نوعا ما عذر
المقاطعه ما ذكرته الان هل هو مرتبط لما
ذكره وما جاء في تصريحات الوزير الايراني
بالقول بان تبادل الرسائل مع الولايات
المتحده في مساله رفع العقوبات مستمر هل
هذا مرتبط بذاك
عبد القادر ان هناك ملفين اساسيين هناك
ملف الاتفاق النووي ملف الاتفاق النووي هو
الذي تحدث عنه وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه
يقول بان تبادل الرسائل لا يزال متواصلا
في مساله الاتفاق النووي والعوده للاتفاق
النووي بعد توقف المفاوضات في فيينا وهذا
الامر تصرح به الخارجيه في الكثير من
المرات حتى وزير الخارجيه يقول بان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لم تثبت
جديتها في العوده الى الاتفاق النووي لكن
ملف السجناء يبدو انه ملف منفصل ووزير
الخارجيه الايرانيه كان واضحا حينما يقول
بان هناك اتفاق حول مساله تبادل السجناء
تم مؤخرا وان المساله الان هي مساله تقنيه
ترتبط بالولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
انتظار الاجراء الذي تتخذه الولايات
المتحده في هذا المجال وكما اشرت عبد
القادر على ان الاجراء الذي يتم الحديث
عنه يبدو انه يرتبط بالشق المالي كما
ستسابقا على ان هناك ما يقارب 7 مليارات
دولار موجوده في المصارف مصارف ك الجنوبيه
وتم ايقاف هذه هذا المبلغ بطبيعه العقوبات
المفروضه على طهران من قبل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وكانت هذه هي العقده
التي كانت توقف او بمعنى اخر توقف اي
عمليه للتبادل السجناء منذ اكثر من سنتين
حينما يتم حديث الوزير اليوم على ان
الصفقه تقريبا شبه مكتمله فيعني ان هذا
الشق المالي تقريبا قد تم حله وكما اسرت
كذلك على ان هناك دولتان اساسيتين كانت
تلعب بالضروره ضروره مهما في هذا المجال
وحتى الايرانيين الايرانيون الايرانيين
اعلنوا على ان دوله قطر ودوله سلطنه عمان
يعملان على حل هذه المساله وهي المساله
الماليه وكيف يمكن لايران ان تحصل على
اموالها من كوريا الجنوبيه فبالتالي
الجانب التقني يبدو انه يرتبط بهذا الشق
ويبدو ان هناك تدابير اتخذت في هذا المجال
ما يتم الانتظار انتظاره الان هو بحسب
الايرانيين وبحسب عبد الله هيان ان يتم
اتخاذ قرار امريكي بهذا الجانب وبالتالي
فيمكن ان بشكل او باخر ان يتم الاعلان
قريبا كما قال وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه عن
اتمام هذه الصفقه وهي جزء مما بدا يصطلح
عليه بالسفقات القليل مقابل القليل القليل
من واشنطن مقابل القليل من طرف ايران
باعتبار ان الصفقه الكبرى وهي صفقه
الاتفاق النووي فعلا تواجه مشاكل على
مستوى التنفيذ وعلى مستوى الاجراء وعلى
مستوى التوصل الى اتفاق بعد التوقف
مفاوضات فيينا هناك مجموعه من المطالب
تطالب بها طهران الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الخاصه في الرفع الكامل
للعقوبات المفروضه عليها وكذلك توفير
الضمانات اللازمه للاستفاده ايران من
الاتفاق النووي وكذلك هناك مطالب اساسيه
تطالب بها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وهي
اعاده النظر فيما وصل اليه البرنامج
النووي الايراني كان اخرها التخصيب بنسبه
60% وكذلك خفض التقسيم بنسبه 20% والتعامل
مع الوكاله الذي يبقى لحد الساعه مجموعه
من الاشكالات العالقه لكن بالخلاصه عبد
القادر ما يتم الحديث عنه الان هو صفق
التبادل السجناء ما بين ايران والولايات
المتحده ويبدو بواسطه الدول الاقليميه على
الاقل كما هو معروف اعلاميا دوله قطر
وسلطنه عمان شكرا لك يا نور الدين من ط